BRAM BOUT: All right,
good afternoon, everybody.
My name is Bram Bout, a leader
at Google for Education team.
And I'd like to
talk to you today
a bit more about
what we're doing
in higher education,
for higher education,
with higher education to
create more Brittanys, and more
amazing projects like the
one you just saw up there.
We are going to
talk a little bit
about the cloud for
universities-- what it
means, what it can do for you.
Then do a deeper
dive into genomics,
one area in
particular where we've
seen tremendous use and power
of the cloud in higher education
research.
We'll do a few breakouts to get
your input and your thoughts
on what we can do better, what
we can do to work with you.
And then we'll wrap it
up in about an hour.
So the Cloud for
Higher Ed, we've
been in the cloud for
a long time as Google.
We were born in the cloud, as we
would like to say, back in 1999
or so.
And we've been operating
as a cloud company
from its very
inception ever since.
So in many ways, we've
been investing in the cloud
from the very beginning.
But it's only
relatively recently
that we've begun to take
all that engineering and all
that power out into the
market and give access
to companies and academia
to do something with that.
If you had an opportunity to
see the keynote yesterday,
I think you heard Eric talk
about the opportunities ahead
of it.
You heard Faffa Lee talk about
the power and the potential
of artificial intelligence that
can be powered by the cloud.
And what really excites me
about that is that to me,
the academic world
plays a tremendous role
in making that vision
happen for all of us.
There's a lot of work to be done
to make the cloud work for all
of us, to democratize it, and
to really deliver on the promise
that it inherently has.
So we're very committed.
I hope you walked
away with that message
at the end of these
couple of days.
We already have more than
a billion end users that
are using the Google Cloud.
You may not know or
see this directly,
but those are companies that
are using the cloud to power
services for their users.
We've invested about $30 billion
over the past three years
in Capex to build out
the cloud network, which
is a substantial
multiple actually
of what our competitors
are doing in this space.
And we have a global network.
About six regions right now,
and adding nine more this year.
That gives you, again, an
idea of how aggressively we
were expanding and
investing in this space.
And we're investing heavily in
the networking aspect of this,
too.
So when you are operating
in a Google Cloud,
you essentially are
everywhere worldwide
through Google's
own private network.
As an example, we just laid
another 60-terabyte-per-second
cable between the United States
and Japan to build out that
network even further.
And we will continue to
invest in that going forward.
And then lastly, specifically
for the higher education
community, we just recently
in 2016 joined Internet2--
obviously a well-known
organization of research
universities in
the United States.
And we are working
with them on a number
of what I think are going to
be very interesting projects
and ideas to bring the
Google Cloud more easily
and more powerfully to
the higher education
community in the United States.
And we're working on similar
types of partnerships
internationally to make
that happen as well.
So what does this
all mean for you?
If you are in higher
education, if you're
a university or a
research institute,
how can you use this
to your advantage?
Well, we see essentially
three ways that you can use.
The first way is in the
teaching environment,
just using it to teach the
next generation of students
where cloud computing really
should become or should
be, arguably, a part of every
curriculum going forward,
because it is going to be
so pervasive in the future
workforce that
anyone who comes out
of school in a couple
of years really
ought to know about the
cloud, about data science
and what it can do for
you to make projects,
products, anything better.
The second one is
around administration--
how you run your university.
And that can be the more basic
infrastructure type things,
but it can also be how do you
use the data that you collect,
the data that you have on
the variety of interactions
you have with your
students, your faculty,
your administrative staff.
How do you use
the data to create
insights to run your operation
better-- to do new things?
And lastly, of
course in research,
we will talk much
more about that.
So for education, it's
really about helping
students build what's next.
You saw a great
example of Brittany
just now in the video
at the start of this.
And as I said, this
is something that we
should do much more often.
We already have since
about the summer
of last year, a program in
place for education grants
for Google Cloud Platform.
So this essentially
allows any faculty
to apply for credits
for their students.
Currently, it's limited or
restricted, if you like,
to faculty of universities
that are providing a computer
science type of education.
We're kind of looking
at expanding that.
And up until now, it has been
restricted to the United States
as well.
But I'm very happy to
announce that as of this week,
we're opening that
up to most of Europe,
as well as a few
countries outside of that.
And we will continue to
expand that globally.
So the list of eligible
countries is here.
And if you're from
any one of those,
please take a look at
cloud.google.com/edu and see
if you can get your
folks, your faculty,
interested in signing
up for credits.
Get some exposure,
get some experience
with what the cloud can do for
you in the computer science
environment, and
obviously beyond that.
An example of how this is being
used to make it kind of come
to life a little bit is in
California State University
in San Bernardino.
One group of students
there is using the cloud
to really understand networking.
So they're using the cloud to
configure networks, firewalls,
different routing
mechanisms, creating
false denial of service
attacks to see how networks
react to this and so forth.
And they can do all of that just
sitting behind a computer using
the cloud as their,
essentially, virtual network
that they're running
to see and bring
a lot of what they are learning
in school into practice.
Another example-- you see
the pictures off here--
is for students that are not
actually computer science
students, but
engineering students that
are building a little Rover
with a Raspberry Pi in it,
with some Python scripts
that is talking to the cloud.
And it allows them to
essentially remotely control
that device using a computer
anywhere on campus--
just a really great
interesting project
to illustrate the
power of the cloud
and what it can do for you.
Then on the
administrative side, this
is all about being
more efficient,
and being more
effective, quite frankly,
with your infrastructure.
We have a massive
number of products
out there that will
allow you to supplement,
or if you want to replace
parts of your infrastructure,
in a very efficient manner--
whether that is basic things
like storage or disaster risk
recovery approaches,
or whether that's
a more advanced
use of computing,
like for instance Burse capacity
for your high performance
computing network.
All of those things
are possible.
And I think what we
are very proud of is
we have a very cost-effective
and efficient way to do that.
We also want to
make sure that you
think about what the
cloud can do for you
to make operations run better.
How can you go to
the next frontier?
How can you use the data
you have to do new things?
And one of the topics
that has come up
a lot in our conversations
with universities
is, for instance, the
topic of student success.
Like, how can you improve the
success rate of your students?
How can you intervene
earlier in the process
if you feel that
they're beginning
to go off the rails a
little bit and catch them
before they truly fall off?
So there's a lot of
opportunities to do that,
and we have a number of
products to work with that.
On the efficiency side, we
have very flexible billing
arrangement.
We actually acquired a
company called Orbitera,
if you are familiar with
that, a couple of months ago.
They offer, essentially,
a billing overlay
across multiple cloud
providers so you
can have it all in one
place and really see
who is spending what where
without necessarily having
to get in the way as a
central IT department
and sort of become the
bottleneck for everything
that's happening in
the university, which
is from what we understand
pretty much impossible.
We also offer a lot
more flexibility.
We have, for instance,
customizable VM's.
You don't have to choose
two, four, or eight cores.
You can choose five, if
that's what you need.
Any type of memory
configuration, bandwidth,
and so forth-- it's all very
flexible, billed by minutes,
so you don't pay
in large chunks.
And we have automatic
sustainable use discounts,
which means that you don't
have to reserve an entity
to get good pricing.
If you use an entity
a lot, you simply
get a better price,
because that's
what a sustained use
discount just for you--
as well as future discounts.
If we change our pricing,
and I'm sure we will,
you actually benefit from
that immediately, regardless
of the agreements
you have with us.
On the Big Data
side, we have a lot
of tools that are
very powerful here--
BigQuery, TensorFlow for
machine learning and kind of new
algorithms, particularly good
for structured and unstructured
data.
So combinations of
things that are typically
difficult to manage in
a more classic database
environment, that's
an area where
I think our models and
our products excel.
Hopefully you've had a
chance to learn a bit more
about that in any
of the sessions
here over the last
couple of days.
And if you have
any questions, we
can talk much more about
that a little bit later.
Lastly, and perhaps
most excitedly,
we want to give you the
power to change the future.
We met with a large research
university a couple of weeks
ago and we were talking
about the power of the cloud,
and what can it do, and
how can we work with you.
And they were
saying, yeah, we love
this, because really we
want a partnership where
we can change the world.
We think there is things we
can do in the medical fields
or in the field
even of humanities
where we can have a dramatic
impact if we work together
and bring the power of the
cloud to our research community
to really do amazing things.
Again, we have the basics
in terms of affordability
and access, but we have
also very innovative tools
around machine learning
and advanced APIs.
And I think we are very
confident and proud that we
have these kind of
bleeding-edge innovations,
and that we bring
them into production
and make them
available to everyone
as quickly as possible.
So recent innovations
like TensorFlow,
but also Cloud
Spanner, for instance,
as a globally
consistent SQL database,
are all things
that make it easier
for researchers to use
the power of these tools
very efficiently.
And lastly, you can
start where you are.
We don't advocate
the replacement
of what you have, and just
kind of go into the cloud
and leave everything
else behind.
We really want to
work with you to see
where we can begin to work with
you to expand what you can do.
Again, overflow for your high
performance computing center.
Or even just like a weekend-type
burst for something very
specific-- something we did
with CERN a while back--
can be extremely powerful,
and actually surprisingly
affordable.
We have a ton of products.
I'm obviously not going to
go through each of those.
But to just give
you a feel for that,
and if you walk
around here and have
been able to attend
some of these sessions,
I'm sure you've learned
about some of these.
We have a ton of products
in data and analytics.
We have products in
application development,
all the way from
completely managed--
you just give us
the source code--
all the way back to you do it
all yourself, and pretty much
everything in between.
We have lots of tools and
products around infrastructure
and operations to make your life
easier, whether that's logging,
or log analysis, or
billing and accounting.
So there's a lot of places
where you can start.
And I think one of the
challenges in some ways
is to figure out
exactly how we're
going to go about that, how
we're going to work with you.
Now for many of you, a lot of
these tools may appear new.
And to some extent, they
are, in that we've only
made them available externally
relatively recently.
But take something
like MapReduce,
for instance, which was
essentially developed by Google
engineers in 2004,
a very long time ago
in the form of white papers,
and has been in production
within Google since 2004, that
sort of spun off into Hadoop--
like an open-source platform
for that particular thing.
The same thing with Bigtable.
BigQuery is internally
used in Google
as called Dremel, and has
been there since 2008,
and is still heavily used today.
Even the Cloud Spanner that was
just announced very recently
has been in production
in Google since 2012.
So the benefits you have here
is that you have products that
are cutting-edge, really
state of the art kind of ways
to think about some of
the big computer science
problems of our time, but
that have been tested,
improved, and hardened
at massive scale
within Google-- because
we do a few bytes of data.
And you get the benefit of that
in your production environment.
The moment you switch it
on, you have the knowledge
that this has been
tried and tested
in a very harsh
environment already
for a substantial
amount of time.
So that's one of
the main things I
think sets us apart from
some of our competitors,
is that we have tremendous
innovation, particularly
in the field of big
data machine learning--
and that innovation has
been tried and tested
and will continue to
accelerate over time.
One example of
that is with Cern.
This is one of their
collider units, I think.
I'm not sure exactly
what this is,
but it looks very impressive.
It's what?
Sorry?
The particle accelerator.
There you go.
So what we did with
them-- obviously,
these generate massive
amounts of data
that need to be processed,
need to be visualized,
need to be dealt
with in some way.
So we've become a partner
of their high energy cloud--
high energy physics cloud.
And we're now helping them
and the researchers that
want to use this data to process
this and to churn through this.
And we've done experiments
and projects with them
where we've literally spun up
100,000 cores over a period
of, let's say, a weekend, to
do a very rapid burst of data
analysis that would
have taken months
in any other environment,
quite frankly,
to deliver these
kinds of results
that we were able to do in
a very short period of time.
And that's the really
exciting stuff.
And there's a lot more that
we can do together with them.
The last example I'll
give you of a partnership
is the one with the
National Science Foundation.
We just announced this
a couple of weeks back,
a partnership for their Big
Data Sciences and Engineering
project, where they issued
a call for proposals,
essentially.
And Google is one
of the providers.
We're committing $3 billion
in credits for grants
that the NSF is going to give
for research in this field,
where you can use the Google
Cloud and all of its power,
and all of the
products that we talked
about to continue to develop
Big Data and the science
behind this.
So we're very
excited about this.
We're very excited about working
with a higher ed community.
We've obviously been
partnering with many of you
for a very long time already,
largely in the area of G Suite.
And we're very excited about
opening this next chapter
around the cloud.
We see tremendous
opportunities for innovation,
whether it's in teaching,
whether it's administration,
whether it's research,
there's a lot
of things we can do together.
We're very committed.
I hope you walk away with
that from not just this talk,
but from this entire conference.
And we really see some fantastic
opportunities to work with you.
So with that, I'll
hand it over to Benny
who's going to talk
more about genomics.
Thank you.
BENNY AYALEW: Thank you
all for having me today.
I just want to punch
through a number of things
here in the next
20 or so minutes--
everything ranging from
security and compliance
to the reality of dealing
with both research
and academic
environment, as well as
clinical environments
as it pertains
to the world of genomics.
And then if the demo
gods are with me,
I'm going to go ahead and
walk through a petabyte
worth of cancer genomic
data sort of live,
and tempt the network here.
So we'll have a bit of fun.
So the very first thing I
wanted to sort of touch on
is the typical question
that we get out from folks
that we deal with
in academia and also
in clinical environments.
This is a bit of an
elephant in the room,
so we hear this all the time.
You've probably attended
your fair share of sessions
around security and compliance
in all of the other breakouts
that we've had, so I won't
belabor those points.
But it's really
important to understand
when we get into this space
of data ownership and data
locality, any time you start to
deal with very sensitive data
sets-- phenotypic data sets,
things that are actually
subject to HIPAA, folks get very
understandably very concerned
around what cloud providers
actually have to offer,
and what sort of
capabilities and where
the lines of demarcations are
for whose responsibility it
is to store and
safeguard that data.
So we'll run through most
of the answers for these.
But the main thing to
remember is that, number one,
we do sign BAA's.
And we do, in fact, have some
examples for you on that.
But very often when
you start to look
at the regulatory and compliance
templates to which Google
itself holds itself accountable
through external audits,
it very often meets and
frequently exceeds the letter
and the spirit of the
controls stipulated
in a lot of these
data protections.
So the very first
example I'll talk through
is the Clinical Genomics
Service at Stanford University.
I've had the
tremendous privilege
of being able to work
with the folks there
over the last few years.
And this was sort of a
collaboration that started out
in very early days
for Google in terms
of sort of foraying
into that space,
and really resulted in this
ongoing and very virtuous
collaboration between both
the clinical environments,
as well as the School of
Medicine within Stanford.
So just a quick recap around the
use cases in Dr. Merker's lab
and in that
environment, the pilot
kicked off sort of in the
January 2014 time frame.
And this is an area
where, obviously, Stanford
being world-renowned, is
an area that actually folks
turn to when other care
providers have been completely
stumped in terms of
investigating very
rare diseases, familial
diseases, things that have been
very, very difficult to diagnose
and get to the root cause of.
And obviously, genomics
has been shedding light
into how some of
those can actually
be a little better diagnosed
and a little better treated.
So some of the challenges
that they actually ran into
was not knowing what
sort of ends they were
dealing with right off the bat.
I mean, people can estimate
to see how many cases
you might get in
a particular area,
but imagine having to
build capacity and think
about putting out the
capital expenditure
with an uncertain amount
of investment in mind.
The other aspect also
is that there's just
a tremendous amount of
dynamism between the folks
who are in clinical environments
on the hospital side
providing care, but also
very actively collaborate
on the School of Medicine side.
So a person who might be
a given Google identity
might navigate across regulated
and controlled boundaries,
and so how do you sort
of solve for that?
And those were some
of the challenges
that we overcame together.
The bit around elasticity
was a significant problem
to overcome.
And of course,
obviously, for that,
the Google Compute Engine
and the Cloud Platform
were able to be a fit there.
The other aspect also was
flexibility in the language
in our terms of service.
Of course, obviously,
the lawyer cats,
as we like to call
them in Googleland,
have a good bit
of back and forth
in terms of the red
lines that typify
the sensitivities around this.
But we were just in a
fantastic partnership together
and were able to forge
this alliance going forward
in tackling both the
technical and the legal issues
that were required for making
this service actually light up.
And so for that, there
were a number of solutions
that actually came into being.
Obviously, Google Cloud Platform
solved the storage aspect
of issues.
Google Genomics is
a managed service
that actually allows
for a genomic sequence
analysis on our
platform where you
don't have to spin up
machines and download
your favorite
bioinformatics tool,
and then compile it, and then
run it, and go through all
of that common back and forth.
You just basically bring your
data and then invoke the API,
and get your reads and variants
in that particular area.
BigQuery obviously was
also a huge part of this,
because in the
world of genomics,
which is a very sort of
staged analysis world--
the tertiary
analysis, or the sort
of so-called so what
phase, is an area
where we've been hosting
a tremendous amount
of public data sets that
we've made available
that I'll walk you through.
And so this is basically a
conglomeration of both managed
services, as well
as unique capability
that exists on our platform
that we're able to provide
the solution for Stanford.
And I reckon that
speaks for itself.
From my good friend
Somalee Datta
in terms of tackling
these problems,
these are the typical
issues that we
tend to see in
campus environments
where, yes, the campus
cluster was sufficient
for a number of analyzes,
and will continue
to be viable and useful for
the time period going forward.
But when it starts to get to
burst analysis and being able
to deal with
multiples of hundreds
of terabytes' and often into
the petabytes' worth of space,
that's really the
space for cloud,
and it's really an end
world where the data sets
and the analysis pipelines
are straddled between both
environments, and it's not an
or solution where everything
shifts over from
one to the other.
Another example of
what we were able to do
around genomic research
was our collaboration
with Autism Speaks.
And here's an area where
it's actually multinational.
There are cohorts of autistic
children's and familial sort
of quintuplets
quints of data sets
that actually are contained
in this environment that
are used by researchers both
inside the US and, of course,
abroad as well.
And so what we were
able to do there
was almost analogous
to the Stanford case
where we provided both
solutions, as well
as the open access to that
dataset for researchers
to be able to come in
and make use of it.
Another area that I'll just
jump into in the spirit
of the opening
video to the session
is really around the
area of cancer research.
The Institute for Systems
Biology have, in my mind,
done a very exemplary job of
managing that really fine line
between allowing an environment
for researchers and clinicians
to come in with very
sensitive and private data,
but then be able
to do that analysis
in the context of public data
sets like the Cancer Genome
Atlas, which, by the
way, in its natural form
sits on a government site
nicely zipped up and weighs in
at a petabyte.
And so if you're a
cancer researcher
and you want to do that unit
of work, which is a tumor
normal peer analysis, your
step zero of that pipeline
is go ahead and
download a petabyte.
That make get you very unpopular
with some of your storage
admins on campus.
But we've actually made
that a very simple exercise
to go through.
And so I'm going to
go ahead and jump
through a couple of live
demos just to give you
a sense of what that
actually looks like
and what that feels like.
So this is the ISB site, and
it's actually open in public.
And I think the part I was
saying that was very exemplary
is really depicted in this
part of the web page done
by the team over at ISB.
And this really solves the
three key constituents,
which is the principal
investigator,
the computational
researcher who's
very, very comfortable
in Python, or R, or just
in SQL, and then of course,
the algo developer who
doesn't want to see anything
but usually a command prompt.
The red boxes
there are obviously
signifying user data,
which is completely private
to the individual
researcher, not
for group sharing
or public sharing.
And then the availability
of open access data,
which is obviously
the Cancer Genome
Atlas, and a number of
other data sets of interest
and of high value for
analysis are signified there
in the green.
And then the orange
one is a peculiar one,
and that actually
goes into the database
of phenotypes and genotypes.
It's called DB Cap.
And it's essentially a
controlled access dataset
that has sometimes identifiable
data intended for consumption
by qualified researchers
So you can now
imagine a world where
the storage is taken care of.
And for qualified
researchers, they
can now have sort
of a workbench area
where they can
actually do their work
and do their analysis
in the context of both
their private data sets
that might actually
belong to a patient
that they're treating
or a clinical trial that they
may be a part of, but also
in context of larger public data
sets, and as well as controlled
access datasets, without having
to go and change their work
bench or retool in any way.
So they can do that for storage,
they can do that with BigQuery
for tertiary analysis,
and then they
can do it using our
Google Genomics.
And they're able to
pull off this magic
without having to give up
any level of flexibility
to the lower left
that you see there,
which is that world of
complete open pipelines
where you can now bring in
your favorite Docker container
and install this newest
version of an analysis tool
and still be able to take
part in this virtual cycle
without having to
really break anything.
So as we jump into that,
you can see the first thing
that happens is it'll prompt
you for your OAuth credentials.
And it just opens up
with this blank space.
And it has the notion
of a workbook concept.
And that workbook can use all
sorts of different analysis
types and different plot types
that you can now put into it.
But just as interestingly,
the business
of creating cohorts from
very large data sets
is a unit of work
in cancer research.
So don't blink for this
part, because we're
going to click this bit,
and what you'll see is--
OK, that just
happened way too fast.
I didn't even get
a spinner on it.
That just loaded and
visualized the entire TCGA
all on a single page,
which is extraordinary,
because this sort of passes
the [INAUDIBLE] test.
If you can get a CS guy to walk
through cancer genomic data
and make some sense of
it, and navigate it,
then I think it's met
the usability test.
So if I now want to
go ahead and create
a cohort of, say, all females--
and I'm interactively
walking through this
and it's just spinning it
up as it's going along--
whose cancer was diagnosed
between those age ranges
and who are smokers, as
just a simple example.
And now I've whittled this down
to 115 smokers who are female
and between the
ages of 10 and 39.
Now I can go ahead and
walk through and figure out
if these cohorts were
part of any given study--
which one of them
are alive or dead,
sample types, where the
tissue was actually picked up.
And I can now go in and
save this as a cohort,
and then share it with
another collaborator.
One of the other
things also is that you
have some additional data,
like gene expression and mRNA,
and all sorts of
things that are clearly
of interest to people who
would work with this data
over and over.
So now I'll go ahead and choose
to save this as a cohort.
And I'll just say--
OK, e-mails.
Maybe if I switched off the
search page, that might work.
Hang on here.
I'll just type the
word test in there.
So once this cohort has now
been created, what I can do
is go ahead and share it
with another collaborator.
And say, hey, for that clinical
trial that you're working with,
how does this particular cohort
look like in your analysis?
The other aspect also
is if I've got multiples
of these I can now
start to do set
operations on these--
not in, or complement,
or intersection, and so on.
So these are units
of work that would
have required lots and lots
of coding, and lots and lots
of data wrangling, which
are now made very, very
interactive and useful.
And then the part that
I was mentioning around
that DbGap credential is that
for the same cohort that I just
now created, if I am
a qualified researcher
in an academic environment, I
can now go in and put my DbGap
details into this
page and authenticate
into that secure environment.
And now I can get additional
data brought back,
additional results brought
back, from my same query.
I don't need to go and
recreate it all over again.
It's a very, very
seamless integration.
So those are just a
couple of examples
I wanted to walk you through.
We've gone ahead and
created on Google Genomics
a tremendous amount
of content intended
for consumption by researchers
and folks in academia.
There's our GitHub page.
I meant to actually
go to this page.
The very first item
that you'll see--
the keywords are Google
Genomics cookbook--
is this very rich and
continuingly growing
data set that,
again, really removes
the friction out of having to
do a bunch of heavy lifting
and copying and duplicating and
localizing of data to just get
the work done of
continuing the research,
rather than dealing
with the data wrangling.
So those are just a
couple of examples
I wanted to go ahead
and walk you through.
And obviously, within research
and collaborative environments,
notebooks are a very popular
item and environment.
So one thing I wanted to just
sort of quickly leave you with
is that we also have Google
Cloud's data lab environment,
which is really hosted Jupyter.
And it allows folks to be
able to connect naturally
into BigQuery query
and everything else
in our environments,
utilizing this environment.
So that's my piece.
Thank you.